shanell from new york to present the
best song award is Miss babydoll herself
miss Carol Baker
hi Carol how you running
fine Terry good Carol you must be
thrilled you went from comparative
obscurity to stardom with one picture
yes I really am very fortunate yes you
are and it's a wonderful thing ladies
and gentlemen this is a girl who was
practically unknown a short time ago he
was a real success story tell me Carol
was it fun working in baby doll oh yes
it was thrilling going on location but
that broken-down southern mansion we
lived in was too much no furniture no
heat no plumbing and the roof caving in
you know when I first came in Hollywood
I rented a house like that in Beverly
Hills well why would you want to live in
a house like that
it had a pool and now the best song in
Hollywood the winner is whatever will be
will be from the man who knew too much
hey okay
I promised myself I'd be very calm about
this but it's impossible thank you very
much
let me sit in Evans you know it's funny
about that Carol Baker a few years ago
she came out to Hollywood not buy a
luxury airliner and not buy the super
cheap she hitchhiked and this wasn't
easy with a thumb in her mouth that's
all right don't try and make up